i'm will yakowitz a staff writer at
forbes magazine where i cover cannabis
al harrington is a former nba player
played for the the denver nuggets the
new york knicks the indiana pacers al
harrington started a cannabis company
named viola and it operates in
california michigan
washington and oregon i also cut a
licensing deal in canada and he's going
to expand it to a couple other states
throughout the u.s viola has raised
about 36 million dollars and its
valuation is roughly 100 million last
year the company brought in 20 million
dollars in revenue when i got into 2011
i was just trying to figure out what the
hell i was doing and how i was going to
even start a business but it took me
about three years in
when i started to you know
do more research about the history of
cannabis on the war on drug side of
things when i realized that
you know 85 percent of all drug arrests
and black communities have been cannabis
related it just really opened my eyes
that like you know we cannot let this
industry continue to move forward
without proper representation and
diversity you know in the space i
started working with a group here in l.a
called ggc that you know enlightened me
to a lot of you know things that i just
didn't know
and you know once i started to get that
knowledge i realized that i needed to
change kind of our course of you know
that we were going
um and it wasn't all about just fighting
the stigma but it was also you know
trying to figure out how we can right
the wrongs you know and use our company
as a platform to actually do that one of
the most important aspects of viola is
that al harrington is african-american
and that's a big deal because in the
cannabis industry which generated 25
billion dollars in sales last year only
two percent of companies are black owned
al harrington wants to grow viola's
business he wants to increase the
footprint to 15 states within two years
but he does have a grander vision he
launched an incubator program which he
plans to use to help create 100 black
millionaires in the cannabis space his
ultimate goal with incubator is to
increase equity and ownership and
diversity in the cannabis industry you
know i think that the main reason why a
lot of people especially people of color
miss out on unbelievable opportunities
because it's just a lack of
communication and it's really just about
you know educating our people and giving
our people um access to knowledge
which will obviously i think will
eventually turn into opportunities you
know we try to do it through employment
um we try to do it through our incubator
program you know we just really just try
to reach out and just try to have an
impact as best that we can
one of the companies harrington has been
incubating his gold standard farms which
is a hemp farm in milton tennessee gold
standard has a really fascinating and
rich history so the current ceo jarrell
howard his great grandfather started the
farm in 1941. jerrell howard's great
grandfather was a sharecropper who
descended from enslaved people in
mississippi gold standard started as a
soybean and corn farm and for 80 years
they've been
judging along having a profitable
business but not making great money in
2018 the price of soybeans crashed in
the u.s jerrell howard needed to figure
out his next cash crop to sustain the
family business so that same year the
farm bill passed which legalized
industrial hemp and so when he was
thinking about
the next crop to use he started kind of
doing numbers right and he said okay soy
gets about 600 an acre but hemp could
fetch as much as 10 grand an acre so the
economics were a no-brainer so jarrell
had to pitch his company's board of
directors which are all related to him
you know eight elders ages 50 to 90. he
proposed doing hemp and they said yes
but you need a mentor and he found one
in al harrington the big problem was
that he didn't know him he started out
messaging him on linkedin there was no
response so he planted some hemp did a
harvest and then he started crossing
different strains and he came up with
what is now his signature product which
is purple hemp viola's logo is also
purple so he sent a sample to harrington
and he and he you know got back right
away harrington was really impressed and
was really impressed with the fact that
jerrell howard pivoted his family
business into hemp from soybeans and
they started working together
the transformation of gold standard
farms business has been dramatic over
the last 40 years the farm made nine
hundred thousand dollars in revenue
after it pivoted to hemp gerald howard
says he expects the company to make
three million dollars this year it just
goes to show you like you know this
cannabis is is definitely a huge
opportunity and you know we just got to
figure out ways once again that some
make it something out of nothing thing
this is a farm that's been 40 acres
that's been sitting there for 80 years
and you know obviously barely making it
essentially right to now you know being
able to transfer to him and look what
happened and i think there's a lot of
other opportunities out there like that
and that's what i just try to make
myself available to those opportunities
another method harrington is using to
mint cannabis millionaires is through
his other company called village llc and
that company pursues licenses in
certain states to grow sell manufacture
cannabis and these licenses are
inherently valuable especially in states
like
illinois maryland where the number of
licenses the state has decided to give
out are limited these licenses are
valued at three five ten million dollars
depending on the state depending on the
location that you get you cannot operate
a cannabis business without one of these
licenses and if you're in a state that
has a cap on the number of licenses
they're going to give out that drives up
the price what harrington has been doing
is um he'll find an entrepreneur in in a
state that he wants to start a business
and and partner with them our biggest
thing is just trying to get as many
people as we can to be able to take
advantage of the opportunity in the
right way that's why i think it's so
important that our people get some of
these licenses because we know how to
have the proper impact we know what
initiatives to push and different things
like that you know we have that know-how
so that's why once again it's so
important that you know we have a seat
at the table one of the entrepreneurs
that harrington has helped become a
millionaire through this licensing
process is this guy abe givens givens is
from missouri so when that state was
opening its medical marijuana licensing
process he told harrington that they
should apply how they structured it was
that it would be abe givens his license
he would launch a business in
partnership with harrington and given's
cousin who's larry hughes another former
nba player
they ended up getting a license and now
they're gonna open two dispensaries and
one cultivation site it's very tough you
know working with startups right because
like i said you know cash is you know
tough to hard to come by right now and
the industry goes up and down one minute
is all kind of cash available i mean
it's it's not
so it makes it tough but you know for me
i just i try to invest in people you
know i got to believe in the story i got
to believe in you you got to sell me so
far i feel like i've done a pretty good
job of that because everybody that we
pretty much bought in you know we still
continue to work with and we're just
just trying to grow you know brands
wanted one you know one brand at a time
black americans are almost four times as
likely to get arrested for a cannabis
offense than white people even though
usage rates are the same
so one of the big motivators for for
harrington is the impact that the war on
drugs had on people of color in america
he grew up being profiled and searched
by the police he told me this story that
you know almost every afternoon during
the school week him and his friends
after you know playing ball would go to
the corner store and hang out every
afternoon sure enough three to four
police cars would come and tell
everybody to get against the wall and
turn their pockets inside out and they'd
be searched and these are children these
are nine-year-old children it was scary
you know what i'm saying just not
knowing i don't know if they're going to
lock you up it was [ __ ] up but you
know what i mean it's just it just kind
of came with it that's just that's just
how that's just what happens it lingers
i mean i'm 42 years old obviously a
millionaire multi-millionaire living
nice houses all everything the nice cars
everything but still when the police
pulled me over i still i'm scared
because i don't know how it's going to
end up
as he started his cannabis business and
he started you know talking to people
about the war on drugs he realized that
like that's that's his experience and he
realized it's his own community's
experience and so this is a major
motivator for why harrington wants to
create a hundred black millionaires in
the cannabis space and increase
diversity and inclusion in the industry
how can
this drug have done so much harm in our
communities and now is this new billion
dollar industry and
not only are we not in position to you
know
participate but we're still locked up
behind it cannabis is still being police
the same way in our communities and i
think that that's another reason why you
know as the industry does grow when we
think about trying to create businesses
cannabis businesses within our
communities there's so much
uh fight back i always say like our
communities just have this ptsd they
don't they just can't understand that
like this is a real opportunity where
you know generational wealth
can come from this and we understand
that this fight is going to be a fight
that's going to be forever you know what
i mean i don't think that i'm ever going
to wake up one morning and say job well
done when we finally got there you know
i think this is going to be an issue
that's going to be around for a very
very long time but i think the more that
we continue to put it on the forefront
and make it an issue i think the change
will eventually happen
[Music]